[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis là ce soir pour vous poser une
question est ce que le travail peut être
une plateforme pour nous aider dans la
recherche de sens dans notre vie
personnelle
cette question certes n'est pas nouvelle
elle a déjà été posée par plusieurs
philosophes plusieurs chefs
l'administration et plusieurs experts en
gestion travail du latin tripalium veut
dire instrument de torture
donc je vous laisse réfléchir à quel
point cela est lié avec une quête de
sens cela dit au centre mon entreprise
ça fait presque une décennie qui nous
essayons de trouver des différentes
façons de répondre à cette question
je suis associé de hits une entreprise
de création design graphique qui a
baissé à los angeles en californie
et nous faisons de la construction
visuelle et graphique pour des
différents clients qui viennent de
plusieurs horizons et qui ont tous types
de tailles différentes structures
ensemble nous livrons presque une
centaine de projets par an et cela se
fait avec beaucoup d'organisation mais
surtout avec une manière différente de
travailler et c'est ça que je veux vous
parler ce soir
l'entreprise a aujourd'hui dix ans et
nous avons beaucoup beaucoup évolué au
fil de ces dix années
d'abord nous avons changé de produits
nous avons changé de taille
nous avons changé de structure mais une
chose est resté cela était trouvé une
façon d'opérer autrement trouver une
façon de permettre aux gens de vivre
ailleurs là où ils voulaient donc ils
puissent s'inspirer des pays qu'ils
avaient choisis et faire venir cette
inspiration encore vers le travail ces
tissus a rappelé profondément changé ma
vie et changer la vie des gens qui sont
à mes côtés et c'est de ça que je vais
parler c'est soir avec vous je vais
commencer par le début par mon histoire
je suis brésilien
j'ai 27 ans je suis né au sud du brésil
et tout a commencé pour moi en 2008
c'est en 2008 que j'ai pu obtenir une
bourse dans un cours de création
graphique dans une université
prestigieuse de ma région et c'est comme
ça que je suis tombé amoureux de la
création la photographier dollar pouvoir
continuer je me suis battu pour obtenir
la première place dans l'examen
d'admission de cette même université
parce que j'avais pas les moyens pour
financer mes études j'ai beaucoup
travaillé
je les ai eus et 7 universités et m'a
donné de grandes opportunités j'ai pu
revenir en europe pour la première fois
grâce à ça je suis arrivé d'abord en
espagne grâce en prix et après à paris
par un échange universitaire je suis
arrivé à paris à 19 ans avec en rêve
dans le coeur et pas grand chose dans
mes poches
j'avais 19 ans je parlais pas français
j'avais pas de moyens et je connaissais
personne pour subsister je faisais des
petits travail en ligne ici là je
connais des sites j'écrivais pour des
blogs de mode
je faisais aussi de la recherche de
comportement sur sur l'internet
je faisais partie de cette génération
qui a vécu les années de la révolution
numérique qu'on a déjà totalisé et en
expliquer et en essayant de trouver du
boulot et des petits travaille ici et là
j'ai été mis en contact avec deux
brésiliens qui eux aussi en ligne
essayez de subsister dans le même chemin
que moi à los angeles aux etats unis
leur côté ils essayé d'implanter une
opération là bas pour vendre des
services de création graphique à des
clients californien elle a commencé à
travailler ensemble dans un premier
projet qui est vite devenu un deuxième
un troisième ou quatrième
il ya une grande amitié s'est construite
ce qui nous séparait et l océan
atlantique les neuf heures de décalage
mais ce qui nous liait été
et bien plus simple c'était une envie
d'utiliser le travail comme une
plateforme pour nous permettre de vivre
dans les pays qu'on avait choisi de
vivre et pour mener une vie qui était
cohérente avec cette quête de sens cette
quête de personnalités qui nous était
propre à ce moment là l'histoire est
passé très très vite je suis rentré au
brésil pour finir mes études et j'ai eu
l'occasion aussi d'aller à los angeles
rencontré chez 2 qui quelques années
plus tard sont devenus mes associés en
rentrant au brésil aussi tous ces
processus a beaucoup inspiré le travail
qu'on fait on a beaucoup vsg on a
beaucoup nous le monde il l'entreprise
s'adapter à chaque fois à la façon qu'on
vivait pour nous permettre de voir des
deux nouveaux horizons il ya une période
assez difficile en 2014 que
j'appellerais
une réinvention car c'est un moment où
nous avons fait faillite
cela a été un processus très difficile
pour nous nous nous sommes séparés en
s'est mis de côté et on a décidé de
recommencer
c'est en ré partant de zéro que nous
nous sommes inspirés des échecs qui
étaient commis avant et nous avons
décidé de commencer le début ce qu'on
n'avait pas compris à ce moment là est
ce que j'ai compris quelques années plus
tard c'est que je grandissais comme être
humain en est venue est comme personne
et l'entreprise elle aussi elle
s'adapter à notre propre évolution
moi j'ai décidé de rentrer en france
parce que pour moi ça c'était l'endroit
où j'ai pu trouver du sens où tout a
commencé
je me suis en de parler avec mon
meilleur ami dans les rues de paris il
me disait qu'est ce que tu fais là et je
lui disais je suis là pour être fier de
mon histoire à nouveau on s'est inspiré
de tous ses échecs et on a décidé de
tout reconstruire
on a décidé de tout changer on a décidé
de changer la façon comment on faisait
la tarification la façon comment
contrôler le temps la façon comment
avait des relations avec les clients
mais en arrivant à paris vous devez
imaginer à ce moment là que je n'avais
aucune piste de comment implanter le
monde opération ici moi j'étais jeune
étudiant en cinéma paris 8 et par hasard
je reste sur un email de l'université
paris-x nanterre qui me disait vous êtes
étudiant vous avez un projet
entrepreneurial
venez à nanterre pour le programme
étudiants entrepreneurs je me suis
déplacé j'ai été accepté dans ce
programme
et heureusement j'ai retrouvé des gens
qui m'ont aidé avec plusieurs choix des
choix fiscaux des choix stratégiques et
aussi avec toutes les questions de
papiers d'autres questions que je
pourrai retrouver à ce moment là j'ai
aussi fait des très belles rencontres et
aujourd'hui j'ai gardé des amitiés assez
profonde avec de tuer les entrepreneurs
que je peux rencontrer ici et qui aussi
fait face aux mêmes difficultés que moi
comme par exemple la solitude ou le
manque de moyens le manque de plusieurs
choses ensemble avec mes associés encore
une fois on s'est mis à refaire et à
refaire tous ces éléments là mais une
chose nous avons gardé c'était un
nouveau mode de travail et nous voulions
à la fois maintenir cet aspect qui nous
permettait de vivre là où on voulait me
faire une progression à ce que ça soit
possible en a tout le monde qui
travaillent avec nous l'entreprise elle
évolué on avait deux nouveaux membres
dans l'équipe
est ce qu'on voulait faire c'était
d'améliorer ses processus et d'améliorer
cette façon de faire pour que d'autres
personnes soient capables de vivre le
même rêve que nous nous avons augmenté
notre structure et à un moment nous nous
sommes rendu compte que ce que nous
rendait fort c'était nos différences
notre structure était en fait un partage
de différentes façons de voir le monde
les différentes façons de voir la vie on
était plusieurs mais on était aussi
plurielle et c'était cette pluralité qui
était notre force on était ancien kiné
attaché de presse graphistes
photographes chercheurs académiques et
ensemble ces dialogue constant sur les
différentes manières de voir le monde a
créé une espèce de liant une espèce de
scifo comment qui nous unissait et
ensemble d'une seule voix on essaie de
porter un message on essaye d'opérer
autrement on essaye de travailler
autrement
certes cette exploration par rapport à
la façon de travailler n'a pas du tout
été évidente
nous avons fait face à plusieurs
problématiques monde de travail
contemporain le monde de travail
contemporain parfois qui a cette
flexibilité peut venir avec deux côtés
il ya d'un côté notre capacité d'adapter
notre vie professionnelle à ce qu'ils
soient plus en accord avec notre vie
personnelle et cela est très bien mais
de l'autre côté parfois la vie
personnelle va trop dans l'autre sens et
en pair avec le manque de limites et et
la solitude
donc nous avons créé une structure une
cellule dans l'entreprise qui fait que
ça ça permettait ça permettait à ces
problèmes-là d'exister ça a créé du
dialogue et ça nous faisait tous évoluer
notre modèle ensemble on se posait des
bonnes questions
comment est-ce qu'il faut travailler
comme honey ce qu'il faut ce relationnel
commentait ce qu'il faut avancer
et aujourd'hui je pense que cela est
notre force
il ya en anti mites et une amitié une
complicité qui nous lie qui nous rend
soudée qui nous rend fort et c'est
encore une fois c'est dialogue constant
qui nous fait qui nous fait avancer
comme vous avez compris peut-être cette
histoire a été faite de plusieurs
réussites mais aussi de plusieurs échecs
on a réussi on a échoué est loin d'être
finie l'histoire ne vient l histoire
elle vient de commencer
avec la continuation de cette histoire
plusieurs questions se posent
quelle est la bonne structure et assumé
comment on va évoluer en regardant les
mouvements du temps de l'histoire du
monde et aussi nos vies qui sont en
train de changer constamment saison des
questions auquel j'aurais pas de réponse
pour vous ce soir mais sont des réponses
sont des questions qui guideront notre
processus d'évolution
tout au long des prochaines années je
pense que si moi j'ai eu l'occasion de
retrouver ma place ou de trouver ma
place cela était grâce à ces processus
de peser les bonnes questions concernant
vrai très franc avec vous moi je me
voyais je ne vais pas patron je ne vais
pas chef d'entreprise il ya un moment de
mon histoire je me suis retrouvé dans
mes bottes je me suis dit ouh là je suis
entrepreneur du milieu où je viens et de
ma création être chef de quelqu'un être
boss avait quelque chose de ne pas bien
tu pas de pas pour moi surtout pas pour
moi et aujourd'hui ce que je fais et la
façon comment je vois mon travail c'est
de poser les bonnes questions et de
faire en sorte à ce qu'ensemble nous
puissions apporter des réponses à ces
questions là moi je chie gardians d'une
idée je suis gardien d'une philosophie
dans quelque sorte
finalement le terme aux philosophies mme
fehr et venir au thème de cette année
qui est le terme de révolution
quand on m'a invité à venir je me suis
posé la question dans quel sens mon
histoire est-elle révolutionnaire je
pense que cela si cela était une
histoire révolutionnaire ça n'a jamais
été une révolution combative engagé
pilippe militante politisé tel comme on
peut comprendre par le terme de
révolution qui lui est un grand mot
certes on croyait à quelque chose on
s'est battus pour quelque chose et on y
croit encore
mais je pense que révolution ça suppose
leur renversement de brusques de quelque
chose d'une horde établie et si nous
avons pu changer l'ordre établi de
quelque chose l'a été pour nous et cela
a été fait d'une façon qui était
plutôt douce est plutôt silencieuse je
pense que plus que révolution finalement
nous allons vers le sens d'une
progression ou dans le sens d'une
évolution
je pense que nous évoluons vers quelque
chose de mieux et de quelque chose qui
est plus en accord avec notre vision nos
valeurs et notre histoire et ben c'était
cette vision si valeur et cette histoire
que je suis venu partager avec vous ce
soir
merci
[Applaudissements]